elle me fait pas plaisir mais encore une
fois je suis un soldat et la guerre qui
m'est imposé en la circonstance mode
viger avoir recours à ce procédé
je ne considère pas que ce procédé vous
avez soit malgré le mot affreux qui
danse on le qualifie et soit plus
inhumain que de balancer des bombes sur
les populations ou de tirer au feu ou de
se provoquer la france blessures avec
des armes à feu
c'est un procédé nouveau nom employé
intérieurement mais souvent dit ce qui
se résume à peu de choses il s est
beaucoup moins de traces sur les
individus que avec une balle dans le
coeur ou ou simplement à laisse pas les
procédés employés par nos adversaires
fln vis-à-vis de leurs propres frères de
leurs compatriotes qui avaient fui même
loup ou qui n'avaient pas respecté les
autres heures des autres est interdite
du fln là ça va leur couper des camps
s'étaient pas autre chose comme ça c'est
sam barrettes de la torture pour d'avant
ça mais j'ai jamais couper le net
personne moi et mes bouquins mais là non
plus moi je le respecte les opinions de
chacun j'étais navré du 2 est d'être en
opposition avec godard diop est un vieux
copain les étions ensemble à la pêche et
à sa sirène et au jeu des revues depuis
que nous serons là demain moi j'ai rien
contre lui il m'a pas puisque j'ai
raconté cette histoire est que tout le
monde a parlé de la sphère bollardière
si j'avais parlé dans mon handicap
radi bon ben monsieur étouffé la flamme
rouge est affectivement je suis cité des
simplement des textes ailleurs que j'ai
essayé même pu faire rapidement le gros
test dans les quelques modèles
bollardière qui dans mon esprit au moins
six pendant fluide beaucoup de gens
pourra contribuer à faire comprendre
comment il a été amené à prendre cette
position